[Music]
guys hi
hi remember what was that six months ago
eight six months i don't know remember
when we were young
six months ago and we did no it's like
five months
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
don't matter
look you don't come here for time you
don't come here to to have a strict
adherence to time
uh me and bianca fell in love we started
to fall in love
yep and we cut it off before it got out
of hand we were like that's enough of
these questions i'm
falling for this [ __ ] and uh
but there's a second half to the new
york failing new york times
questionnaire of how to fall in love
with somebody
there a total of 36 questions we got
through
21 the first time which is
exactly half if you're doing math hey
and
um so now we're back and i remember last
time while we didn't fall in love
exactly at least i didn't i know you'd
uh because there hasn't been a lot of
screwing um
and you know i love you if i s if i
screw you
um the uh the
but we got to know each other we liked
each other more
way as a matter of fact so that's
something so let's take that energy
and let's go into part two
of neil and bianca fall in love
this question i think we should
alternate
and good thing it says alternative yeah
good alternate
sharing something you consider a
positive characteristic of your partner
share a total of five items
you go
i think that you're funnier than i give
you credit for
that's so good that's worth two
really that really is um
i think you are
[Music]
highly intelligent and very good at part
of recognition
and an intellectual
and i don't think people give you enough
credit for that oh
thank you well intellectuals usually a
boar which they do give me credit for
that
um uh [ __ ] i didn't know i was gonna go
again
um i was noticing earlier today
that you have excellent teeth oh thank
you
especially with that lip with that shade
yeah with the dark the dark the light
i got it makeup pop did you write these
down because i wrote mine down
no i didn't write them down okay uh i
feel like you let's see
okay i feel like in a very particular
way you're extremely open-minded
uh-huh i know what you mean you're until
i made my mind up and then it's shot
well no it's just like if you tap into
the same
vein as your logic if someone can be
like no but this
you're really i feel like you're really
fair okay
and you don't sorry you don't put your
ego in front of it
you really will just drop it if if it
plays the kind of same logic game as you
i was going to say
that in a similar vein number three
because it's compliment number three
that you are
you're more logical than i give you
credit for excuse me
well i can't even say it choked up guys
you're more logical than i gave you
credit for you're not
and then you are okay i don't know about
that compliment
it's another similar there's someone
you're more rational than
most women i've dated because i'm not i
don't think we're dating
but this is not a normal relationship no
it's not
that is a really good way to pull it and
then okay i'm
three uh you will you're
being partners with me in any endeavor
your life will flash before your eyes
multiple times it is a it is a contact
sport
it is it's not easy i got a trail of ex
partners that will attest i know i'm
like
calling up moshe for oh gee i wouldn't
even think about motion
absolutely okay
you have an insatiable thirst for
this is a fortune cookie or this is
something this is my compliment for you
you have an insatiable thirst for
knowledge
about knowledge love and
self-improvement
thank you knowledge about knowledge you
have a thirst for knowledge about
knowledge
interest give me an example okay
um you what you
like knowing why
people are the way they
are in a lot of respects so
i'm trying to think i want to steal
their secrets
it's all under the guise of
self-improvement it's all for that
reason
it's all for wanting to you know
be better be smarter be come across as
all these things so
i think you find a really smart person
and
you try to figure out and i vampire them
and oddly enough you [ __ ] on it a lot
but you really
you really are looking for love and
eternal life and kind of the same amount
yeah
you don't know if it really exists you
don't know if you ever get there but
you're never gonna yeah i have
no idea if that's for me right
but i
i mean yes it's more
uh happiness happiness
but the thing when people go are you
love avoidant
no like i'm not love i want love
yeah it when peop it's like when married
people
act like i'm sick because i'm not
married it's like all right you have
this great
thing and you think that i don't want it
right because i'm sick i'm too
sick to want this amazing the best thing
that can happen to a human being
i'm so sick
i got so much bile coming out of my
pores that i that's
that's so that's your ex that's what
you're telling yourself is that i don't
want that i'm
it's too much yeah [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] him finally my final
compliment for bianca
no you have two more i don't got two
more okay fine
uh cutting one out um
you're interesting
to me you say interesting things
to me on a podcast uh that's actually a
nice compliment
coming from you because you don't find
everyone interesting
no i don't find almost anyone
interesting wow
uh you are uh
very generous very very
very generous you're the poor man's
uh mckinsey basis that's right i only
have 70 million
she's where she has 70 billion if i had
70 million
i don't even understand how much would
you give to
i forgot to talk to you to mention this
when rock was on
what because it's such a testament to
how crazy he is and how
functional it is he didn't know how much
money he had
until he got divorced oh okay yes he had
he literally never asked
how much money he had until he got
divorced
and i was like what dude
and he goes neal what good does it do me
to think of myself as rich now
we both know the answer to that as well
you could maybe enjoy your life more
but that's not what he's here for he's
here to [ __ ]
to think he's under attack and then
strike back
with a good bit yeah uh
so but not like he had i don't know how
much money yet but actually i do but i'm
not gonna tell you
um but he but after a certain point
it's like what are you doing this for
uh i don't i i just i
now having said that i'm only generous
if i've recently
received money like
there are points where if i get like a
profit statement
or whatever whatever uh and i'll see
like
then i'm that weak i'm like [ __ ] yeah
licking my finger a lot and then
two weeks later i'm like i can't i don't
think we're gonna shop
you've really been hitting the amazon
hard um so thank you for noticing my
generosity
yes uh just mention it at my funeral
when people are shooting on me and
talking about how cold and mean i was i
wonder what will's gonna say
no comment um well
will is a fan of my directorial movie
the goods
i just found out so yeah pretty big deal
saw it in the theaters thanks will
got me nothing because i didn't have
points on it doesn't make a difference
if you go see
it numb next question
how close and warm is your family
do you feel do you feel your childhood
was happier than most other people's
yours is well listened to the first part
yeah
if you listen the first falling in love
episode i read through my mother's rules
which made your mother cry and made
jimmy carter tear up
so so sad um a stoic brit
was brought to heel
uh he pulled over on the side of the of
the
tram i can't remember what they called
over there uh the motorway
too so
sometimes i think i overstate
the how i grew up
like i'll have sometimes i'll have
memories and i'll be like well that's
[ __ ]
like we had a pool you wouldn't think
you know what i mean like
you wouldn't think we had a pool i never
used it because i would just go to work
because it it wasn't worth it just
wasn't worth like i'm not i didn't get
my drive i didn't get my
i didn't i moved to philly in eighth
grade so
i was only there for five years so like
i didn't get a license because i just
didn't want to [ __ ] with my dad's car
i like wouldn't use that it was just
like [ __ ] all this [ __ ] um
close and warm
the category is close and warm
not that close
but a little warm certain people i'm
warm with
not those sandwiches listen i can't
right
yeah i can't get over that to me feels
like coldness it is cold
well they were cold technically but the
active that whole rule board yeah that
feels so cold
yes yes it's it it
was like a like a group home
for but the same family but then i think
i it's like am i
being a dick by saying am i being um
self-pitying by saying like it's like a
group i'm like no people i i don't think
me and tiffany haddish's upbringing
right no i mean like that's real
pain and squalor and i don't know
squalor but real pain
and and and like no almost no
she didn't have a pool and nothing
positive
right um do you ever hear around the
champs it was like the best
it was like i'm sure it was really like
a coming out party bird
it was all anguish yeah it was just all
like
bad like abuse and how do you interview
when someone's saying such like
just [ __ ] up stories how do you guys
well people thought
i was being too funny with brock
what on our episode
really yeah because i was laughing at
how
awful some of the [ __ ] he was saying was
yeah but i'm laughing at him
for not admitting it was awful for 50
years
until i was like it seems awful and him
going like what
um so
yeah i don't i think with you
if someone knows that you've been
through similarly bad [ __ ] or
you you can ask the questions it's not
and you know how to ask it
meaning you know what you take it from
their point of view
and like that must have been awful
instead of like
tell us right without being uh like a
anguished tourist about it
um and i happier than most people
no no but
there are plenty people with
significantly less happy childhoods
so millions and millions of million i
mean yeah it's hard
it's hard again you can't compare
this is a rock argument we used to have
where he's been like
rich kid knowledge i was like you know
so compare grown-up brooklyn to africa
you had a great
yeah there's always it's like and then
africans go what what country like
there's just you can get worse and worse
and worse
yeah so um i
had a split parent uh
home or growing up situation so both
very close
just you were close with both of them
close yeah and the
the dynamic is close there's no room to
really be
distant were your mom and dad still
close hell no
hell no do we know what happened ah
i haven't really agreed i've never
really gotten the full story but
um a lot of miscommunication
a lot of some weird
some bad choices in retrospect some bad
from both of them
i think so i think people are being
petty
and hurt feelings and people went to
their respective corners and then
life did something yeah but
so always close and relatively warm my
dad's
less warm sometimes just really
stern stoic immigrant middle eastern guy
you know persian guy
uh but had a lot more money
so you know it's like i went skiing
every weekend we were with him in the
winter like
that's very nice you know i'm not gonna
go hey there's
not that many black people on the slopes
right that's so very painful tell us
about that that was not
that way you know me my brother made it
work how do i ask about pain
this is how talk to us and
tell people what it was like to ski
skiing while black first of all
anyways and then my mom's you know
definitely not like that but still found
you have fun when you're a kid you'll
figure it out i don't need you
your dad
okay if you were in a divorce situation
do you think it behooves the
richer person
i mean i guess you're you're constantly
jocking i was going to say
do you think it it it's it's not good
for the kid to go from
not from rich wealth to poverty no but
me
like one weekend like like should the
richer person be like [ __ ]
to give like let's smooth the diff it's
called
smoothing well now they do that where
it's like oh the kid should not
feel a difference in lifestyle so that's
when a lot of
it's a horrible trauma a difference in
lifestyle uh that's what a lot of
that's a lot of settlements for that
that's a lot of settlements that are
huge yes is because well 90 grand a
month for
for events right so i
will say my therapist thinks
that my uh ocd comes from
that stress as a kid being in like
every week being in a completely
different environment in a household
i don't know i think you know yeah
sometimes therapy feels like
a crystal ball i've started referring to
therapy as a place i go
and recite my problems
now i'll do a recital of my issues and
nothing
i'll just do that for years no my
therapist
is like gives some i don't know if he
he gives me some advice i don't know if
they're supposed to give it to us i mean
i'm
not advice but just he will it i get a
lot from therapy
he's great he doesn't just i have
friends that are like
how did that make you feel tell me about
that did you like that what what was
that like
a lot of that [ __ ] no mine is very a
little more aggressive
yeah i like it whatever but uh he does
he made and i won't go into it because
it's kind of a long thing but
he made a really good argument that he
thinks at such a young age going into
when i tell you 180 opposite
households every week for
like from five to from four or five to
like 17 it's just really formative
yeah so same school though
what do you mean you oh yeah we didn't
yeah yeah you know
uh yeah relative not near but same city
not near yeah like your dad was
nowhere wanted nothing to do with where
your mother was living oh it wasn't that
bad lock the doors kids were going to
pick up bianca
um this is a very funny one i
actually i didn't even see this one this
is right up your alley how do you feel
about your relationship with your mother
oh my goodness uh well she's a feeler so
i feel great
um it's a little complicated i love my
mom very much
she's but she should have been richer
you gotta
deduct points right i mean right there
right there
no no she uh i just um our
relationship is really complicated it's
just a really complicated relationship
like we
get along and we also really want to get
along
but i think
she like i over worry about her and she
i think she feels like i'm very
controlling
to her in particular so i think she
feels like
i don't let her you don't let her smoke
dupes
no she smokes noobs but she i think i
she feels like i parent her interesting
and i feel like
she needs a parent a little bit of a
parent so
it's interesting uh because usually when
that happens
it's because the
parent asks kind of asks for it so she
has she wouldn't
but you are right so it's your
interpretation of what asking for it is
uh i really try to not i try very hard
to not but it's just like
there's times i'm just like
what are we doing and i
it's a weird switch that happens
sometimes
i think it always ends up happening you
go from
you know being parented to parenting
like if they're really old it's like no
mom eat your you know whatever
but i don't know it's
it was not that old so i think she finds
it
uh a little overbearing
trying to be careful here yeah yeah
that's funny that's i wouldn't
the only people i know with that problem
the parents are real fuck-ups
meaning drug addicts drunks like real
and it becomes part of the dynamic i
don't think she is no she's not drunk
that's what i'm saying
it's in i've rarely heard it
about from two ostensibly healthy people
yeah yeah but i also i don't doubt that
it happens i just
yeah i just you know well i'm not going
to
put my mom on blog but uh
yeah i it there's a reason why i do it
you know and she has reasons why she
thinks it's
probably a little bit obnoxious so it's
yeah it is what it is
what about therese you know bianca
uh it is
you know what the the i always say my
mom the thing about i did my best and
all that stuff
i think there it like she did
she was in she's married to an alcoholic
abusive alcoholic yeah so
her her options were limited
in terms of behavior
so that's fine the
it how responsible can i how
how responsible can i hold someone whose
mom died when she was three
and was carted off to separate it from
her sisters and dad
it's like what do you so how how
stern can i be yeah like
even the the amount of kids she had was
like she wanted to
she never wanted to be alone again okay
i can't argue with that
i i know as a person as an adult in 2020
that's kind of faulty logic but
but uh
what i used to i tried it wasn't it was
like a half
thought but so you go back
to her then you go back to her mom
and then the people before that and
these people are illiterate
living off the land they're like cave
people and it's not that long
it's like three generations and you're
into like illiterate
probably violent men uh no school
kids working it's like why
what do i expect like how much can i
expect as a person
to i need you to be
there's not gonna there's not gonna be
uh
there's not gonna be like this great
exchange of understanding
the problem comes when you go all right
well what does that
make me meaning what am i composed of
now
and what do i do about that no kids
that's why no kid i mean that but
honestly i feel like well what am i
if i admit the if i
focus on the worst parts of myself or
maybe i get like a horrible
emotional diagnosis not okay you have
but just like
you are love avoidant you are
uh dismissive you're you put
and then it's like well i get why now
what do i do
like narcissism is a disease that
the the the uh patient is happy to have
and never recovers from yeah never
so that's not i don't i if i'm
narcissistic i think it's in the mild on
the mild end
it's very hard to overcome [ __ ] like
that
it's very hard to overcome like an
emotional set
like this is how you're set would you
say like heavyset
for for for bad people he's heavyset as
if there was no
they were just set that way he had to be
400 pounds um
that was the setting he was on so if i'm
my emotional set
that's where all the pursuit of this
[ __ ] comes from is
knowing where i'm what the setting is
and just trying to [ __ ]
nudge it off of it and
to varying degrees of success in some
parts of it i've nudged it
probably 25 some parts it's like three
i'm not trying less do you know what i
mean like i don't
it's like if you're gonna build yourself
over
i'd keep obviously my
work ethic and my sense of humor right
and my
aesthetics but the rest of it
my emotional approach is like oh i am no
attachment to that
yeah but that's the thing like people my
mom's generation
feel like attached to their
like well that's how i've done it it's
my it's like it's tradition everybody
like we've met here every year it's just
a dumb
superstition or tradition that i've
never
had ever like i started going to third
room it's like 23 i was like i'm not
[ __ ] married to this [ __ ] at all yeah
but the problem was in some ways you are
yeah in some ways
you are the it's really hard it's just
kind of getting
self-aware and nudging self-aware and
nudging
it's really hard to be like i'm a new
nail
whenever someone says i've changed like
no it's just like if you're like
at the store like no we are good tippers
we'll take care of you
no no you wouldn't mention it
good tippers don't mention it it's true
um
so so that's how i feel about my mother
number 25
make three true we statements each for
instance we are both
in this room feeling blank
blank um i will say we're both in this
room
feeling connected
okay do we alternate
yeah we'll alternate uh we both so it
said for instance i'm not using the
both in our room we both enjoy the world
of comedy and have unique
insights i'm going back to the room
we're in this room
[Music]
we are both in this oh we statements we
uh enjoy i would say enjoy doing the
podcast
even though it can be a pain and
we can have flare-ups
argument argumentative flare-ups we get
some flare-ups
that we've gotten better at um getting
through
and just letting it live in the past
um we both pay attention to slash hate
the same kind of cringe behavior great
although i do not like the word cringe
well
there's no better one what's the better
one
embarrassing embarrassing yeah but the
problem with cringe is like
it's that like but i find cringe makes
me cringe
cringe makes me cringe too but sometimes
something's not embarrassing
it's just cringy like a word someone
keeps using it's not necessarily
really embarrassing if you've if you're
if you're a big enough snob it is
right but then somebody else it's just
like can you stop
like just uh it's not necessarily
embarrassing i feel like cringe is
cringe too
is personally and embarrassing is no one
i don't know i don't but i i would argue
that we can just use it for both
yeah i i would yeah i would argue i just
everything makes me cry
it's like everything makes you cringe
yeah it's like when people go you're
basic
it's all [ __ ] basic most of most of
everyone's behavior is basic
um and thirdly
i was gonna say that i like
i i hope people do these themselves
because like that thing i've just said
about
um starting my relation my
starting building rebuilding myself i've
never thought before
i've literally never thought that before
and i'm like that's a good that's a
worthwhile thought yeah so i i hope that
we both feel
like this is valuable yes okay and i
said we both enjoy documentaries we do
we do by the way there's one that i
should have talked about
last week which is um dick johnson is
dead
it's uh it's you never know when it's
going to happen
um dick johnson's dead it's on hulu i
believe wait
no it's on netflix it's a this woman
filmmaker uh dp
made uh it's kind of defies explanation
but her father's dying
oh yes okay and netflix it's
yeah it's just really it's an abstract
documentary
cool that i do love that i don't even
know
what the premise is exactly if that
makes sense there are there are
scenes where i'm like i don't know why
this scene is in the movie but i'm glad
it's in the movie
there's i've seen a few they're my more
like art house-y
yeah talks did you ever see my winnipeg
no
it's like that but i did see the
american ruling class
um which uh
probably similar
i can't it just defies yeah it's
it's i don't even know how to describe
it but there's like
monologue it's just crazy it's great
it's abstract and like yeah
but the dick johnson's dead is [ __ ]
super cool
and very sweet the guys are just a very
sweet man
um it's also nice to see
parents and children love each other
even
when they don't have anything in common
yeah they just don't have a ton in
common but they do love each other and
it's not strained at all
that's beautiful
um complete this sentence i wish i had
someone with whom
i could share that's a good one
my humor with and i mean it like
not like i wish i have had that but
that's important to me that you guys
that you can be funny together do you
find that you
often don't have that no or that's like
the downside of being single
no it just i think that is a criteria
um i don't even i mean i see that as
in a relationship but at the same time
if you said this in a relationship it
would go badly
what i wish i could share i wish i had
someone with whom i could share
like just your your type of humor mm-hmm
i don't think that's weird why is that
weird
because we were dating it would be a
problem
if you were like i wish i thought no but
that's the problem with this
the question is like i wish i had it's
like right
oh well but i think this is a
it's i forget that it's i'm gonna answer
it okay but i'm gonna answer it and see
if you can
re-answer it's not about what
what's important this to me is like i
wish i had someone with whom i could
share
a thing i can't share with other people
oh okay
like my porn preferences
there you go that was my answer but i'm
just it's like something
too late there's something
that you generally don't share not
necessarily well
it doesn't have to be like a secret it's
just a thing that
that um you
it's a rare like there are people that
i've met
uh blake first time i met the first time
i mean blake
met and texted i actually said you can't
make
these kinds of jokes like this around
nba players can you
and he was like i can't and it's very
exciting
meaning he's very he's funny he's like
funny for his
for who he is he's very funny so it's
fun to be with somebody that's like
as funny or funny right you're not the
funny guy yeah like you're
yes like somebody will hit the ball back
and then i hit the button
love it um the what i would like to
share
guys
i mean it's a it's it's science fiction
but i wish i could just
down like just download from a from a
plug or a disk
or a drive thumb or whatever kind of
drive whatever however you want to get
it off me
floppy all of my experiences
and feelings and logic
meaning so that someone doesn't okay so
it's just like
there's no that would help you out a lot
yeah it would help me immeasurably
because i i cause i seem weird
and i'm like i'm telling you this is a
true thing that happened
and this is a true way to feel and
um i feel
like misunderstood
not in a way that's
i just i just have had weird experiences
like
ten kids like just [ __ ] like that that's
just not common yeah
um that i wish people could like
and then i would feel
i guess less judged
inherently even though people aren't
judging me i'm like
yeah i would feel less judged
floppy floppy floppy floppy by the way
is the big
is the biggest play in the nba
what the hell is that it's a floppy it's
like a
set it's an nba set it's like the main
nba set like the main play like what
they do
basically every nba team runs some
version of floppy
at its core a floppy action is one where
the ball is at the top the shooter gets
on
under the basket and two screens are set
on each side of the lane the shooter can
choose to choose
the left screen to the right oh
everything's floppy
if the whole league is floppy it's just
obviously except for the triangle
okay how often is the triangle played
well not not anymore
it i don't think anyone does trying what
about the flying v flying vape never no
one's artifact okay
uh you didn't answer the question oh
well on the fly i guess
uh i see a lot of
i've seen so much very subtle
hilarious [ __ ] i mean i've traveled so
many places and
i think i'm good at explaining a story
and telling a story but
i would love there's just things you
cannot explain
everybody knows that i would love the
ability
to kind of taking your floppy thing be
able to just
share just revel with me how [ __ ]
funny this is some things lose their je
ne sais quoi when you explain them and
they're not funny so it would be
version of humor funny scenes that i see
in my life great fantastic
comedy's a big one for her guys she
works in a comedy club
she does like comedy podcasts
um if you were going to become a close
friend with your partner please share
what would be important for him
or her to know that's a weird question i
know
if we were to become a close friend with
your partner please share your friend
what would be oh um just like this is
for people that are not in love
and this can help you fall in love so
let's assume that these are two
strangers okay strangers go uh i would
want
him or her to know that
if i'm being annoying
it's for
i believe a decent reason
meaning i i like i'll find myself
sometimes like with someone i don't know
very well
talking a lot and i'll be but i'm
talking a lot
because i'm afraid they're not going to
talk and it's going to be
we're both going to be bombing don't be
afraid of the silence
early on i'm very afraid of the silence
and everyone
is and should be oh whatever because i
know but i don't it just
then it it just that's an example
i get i mean as a guy i think as a guy
you kind of got to emcee a little bit
you kind of got to like keep it moving
and hey
yeah um women didn't invent magic tricks
i had that thought this week that's a
guy's involvement yeah we did we
[ __ ] gave birth that's pretty pretty
magical nice don't same night dull
um so if i'm being
i nothi i'm not nothing but
if i'm doing something it's not against
you
it's not nefarious it's not it's just
cause like
i this is there's a reason there's a
reason
it's the same issue from before it's
like it's not what you think
you're mis here here's all the
experiences i can tell you my
logic of this and don't
and and feel and i want them to accept
it
and but i don't i feel the relationships
i've had
i feel like they think i'm doing things
they take everything personally like
i mean my friend molly one time said
that women are narcissists and take
everything personally
um which i think is kind of true
um like that she inspired the joke about
when you don't pull a chair out for a
woman
and the girl's like you're not ready to
be a father like how did you
no yours was get a bag of chips didn't
offer me no that's a different
part of the salmon but that's exactly
right like i don't
it's not i'm not a [ __ ] automatic
piece of [ __ ]
there's a reason why i didn't
if i don't put the seat down it's not
because i'm trying to dunk you in the
toilet
it's cause some other it's it i may have
been doing something positive
by leaving the seat up uh
maybe because i peed on it
well why'd you put it up no i'm saying
if i put it up like
it's not because i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's my point is like
it's not cuz you're not thinking me yeah
i'm sorry when i take a leak
i'm not thinking of you i'm sorry but i
don't think that makes me an
automatically a bad person
and i think that that's the thing that i
as a guy i i as a guy
die by the power of demand
that i deal with that it's nothing
personal nothing is personal
other than when it is which is you'll
it's
you'll know yes i'll let you know
this is personal so um
i feel like okay sorry i feel like i
would say
i'm a very supportive friend and i can
be
a bit loquacious can be a little
talkative
um when my like add kicks in
and i'm not moody not very moody
just chill let me
see we're going to ask the judge if
that's if that's true
moody you
used to be moodier you are
difficult i'm sorry i know and i'm just
not that moody
but uh in general but i'm gonna be
straight up with you neil i love you
it was there was an adjustment period i
needed to go through
there were some times where i just
you're the one of the only people that
i've experienced
where i'll give a compliment to you and
get an insult back
i've never experienced that kind of
magical
so there are just things that
kind of threw me off in terms of your
communication style
that was like you know myself one
compliment and one installed out i have
to keep the balance
yeah life felt like there's room
i can't think of a situation though i
totally
believe you i it's so many i have so
many i
um uh there was just adjustments that i
needed to go through and
i'm not making excuses i just am i swear
to god i'm not moody i'm just not
i i know i'm not and you're fantastic
and you've challenged me on how to
communicate with you better and to keep
my cool when you're pissing me off
correct cool love you i'm in love no
empathy
you will receive no empathy from me okay
i feel like we just did this but tell
your partner what you like about them be
very honest this time
saying things you might not try to say i
said so much at the last one i know i
have like one or two
or um well i might have wanted this one
seem like i can [ __ ] go ahead no you
have nice arms
thank you give me a physical one give me
a physical one
nice boobs boobs boobs next
next question um
share with your partner an embarrassing
moment of
your life okay whoa
so i was actually i've had so many
embarrassing moments
i so many funny kinds that could be in
the back of like
a 17 magazine where they're like
embarrassed
i don't know you probably didn't read 17
but they would always have a whatever
and you know i dated a lot of really
young girls go ahead
and i could not think of one because
of course they asked the question and
i'm like [ __ ] what are my hilarious
embarrassing stories i always tell
parties
and i blanked so this isn't the best one
but it embarrassed me very deeply um
there's a bum sorry hobo sorry no
homeless no there you go no houseless
houses yeah what are you saying now yes
uh there was a houseless person
home free not homeward bound
um so there was a house's prison
asking for change some anything can help
so nice pulled up my heart strengths i
walked by i said
you know here you go and you know i gave
him my leftovers
i'm like do you want my leftovers like
yeah
money leftovers thank you so much walked
away
and then and there's a lot of people
around and he just yells
your [ __ ] smells [ __ ] and i was like
i wanted to die
my [ __ ] smells and
was he on the ground yeah
all right how did you know because
because
he didn't get away we always got a case
yeah that's a problem and that's when
i had to stop myself from
saying no it doesn't you know like
defending myself against this guy but it
was
just when someone yells your [ __ ]
smells it's just there's
it's like a hard thing to defend because
it's rude yeah
uh but yeah do you win or do you go into
a conversation you can't be like
all right i'm gonna address this crazy
person
but they embarrass me so do you think he
was talking about you
i think he was i think he was a lunatic
schizophrenic gloomy too
like thank you yeah like it was there
was no rhyme
tourettes it hurt my feelings yeah and i
wanted to go back and take my feedback
that's my burrito that's my wet burrito
okay um
but yeah
maybe that's what maybe that's what got
him there uh-oh oh
vaginas we got a lot of euphemisms for
him guys
embarrassing moment that doesn't start
jerry o'connell oh that yeah
uh embarrassing i mean you could almost
go by era
okay do a do a do a no neil
no neil we know you kind of people know
you
um that's more funny this is the
the thing that made me think of the
homeless thing uh
i was keith had to go
to the bathroom like at four in the
morning which he never does and i
uh was walking him and there was like a
homeless guy
under like right by my house to the like
but like a place they never usually are
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me like
[ __ ] i was not expecting it like a
ghoul and uh and
so we go down to where keith goes and
then
and then where and then i'm like i gotta
we gotta run back
because i just don't i can't [ __ ] with
this homeless guy so
you ran so we're running basically
past the homeless guy and
because who knows what he would he might
have eaten me i mean like i don't know
what i'm even afraid of right
but and i trip basically in front of the
homeless guy
and the funny thing was it was like a
movie
because i kept my eyes open so it was
like a pov shot that like
tilted like homeless guy now i'm
like i turned the phone and kept my eyes
open the whole time
and it was so and he was like i'm sorry
and it was like then he had to apologize
what would you say would you i was like
i i gotta go
oh you didn't say like don't feel bad no
i
he didn't know why i tripped cuz of him
he didn't always running because he
didn't know any of this
um but the fact that i kept my eyes open
[ __ ] made me laugh really so funny um
and then what's it embarrassing
that most of them are just about like
thinking
i was gonna get a compliment and
it ends up being like a trap
where i'm thinking like oh this is good
and then it's like
and then dave chappelle was there i'm
like oh
like okay like i thought it was gonna be
about me
being cool and it turns out but
a little off but but it happens it
happens so much sometimes
that it's like funny you're not offended
oh no i'm offended uh no it's just it's
you can't get offended it's just
like bad luck do you know what i mean
it's just like a bad
what are you going to do yeah like what
no
what what can i do it's like if i think
ah
and then it's like here he is and then
i'm ready
and then she steps out it's just like
i'm not i can't get mad at the audience
it's just one of the even right now it's
a little embarrassing you're like yeah
what are you gonna do
like what i but and that's the thing is
i don't get
it's just like what are you gonna
there's just nothing i can do about it
it's just like
that it's a funny position to be in
it's it's objectively a funny position
to be in that's why i don't
i don't wave to people in sunglasses
like if someone in sunglasses are waving
i don't wave
that was more of an issue on in college
i know that
they weren't waving at you yeah and it
happened once or twice and i just no i'm
never going to put myself in this
yeah i'd rather them be confused than
me to be confused but it's more like on
college college was
campus yeah but it just feels very
presumptuous
and embarrassing and
not good yeah
but i feel like yours probably is worse
it's not
it's just one of those things like where
rock will be like stop
bringing it up i'm like i don't bring it
up
that's the thing that i can never
explain to him or dave it's like i
you guys understand if you're not there
i'm the guy that people reckon you know
what i mean like so they think i'm like
hey everybody you know and it's like no
i don't
if you're not so if people
point and go hey what's dave spell like
it's just a little
it's but it's a fun i it's objectively
funny
by the way you know who would no one
finds it funnier than dave chappelle
because it flatters him and it's
hilarious
it's so funny um but there's just like
yeah
what are you gonna it's like that's what
happened that
if people know me it's from that thing
and then three mics so what am i gonna
so that's what embarrassed that's my how
i define
embarrassment when did you last cry in
front of another person
by yourself go
last time in front of other people was
ayahuasca
and by myself
was during
[Music]
the george floydy
era okay
i think at one point it just got to be
too much
for for for a person
no just i'm not i wasn't crying for me
it was just sad it was just like
sad and i also am very touched by
groups of people doing something like i
can't it's
it's just touching like there's
something so
immutably human and beautiful about it
like they're
the collective is amazing um but if you
go too far you're china
uh let me see what i think i was
watching the news with somebody i cried
at the news
you guys said yeah like
like that like a lead story like yeah
yeah if you they interview the people
and they're all just
beside themselves yeah so sad to me
i don't like it what's great is i just
see them as characters on tv
characters in a story that's not real
you do because we were watching
something in the news came on
and i don't know you just called back
like the title of one of the news
segments
for so long i was like okay well well
that's
i'm making fun of the production no i
know no i know but there's
you find other things funny you can find
something else you can find the
the silver lining in the news um
by myself it's really sad my friend you
know i
there's people you just know and this
was on facebook but
um just anyways you know i just
i don't know if you do this but you
follow along with someone's life that
they have no idea you're
deeply invested like a mutual a friend
of a friend a friend of a friend or a
person that you like don't even keep
contact with
and but you pursue knowledge about them
or it just happens to come
no you pursue like in a hateful way no
and just uh something about this is
interesting to me
like a particular scenario of their life
this will be my last question this is
infuriating what i'm doing uh
no just following along with their life
something about it
intrigues you enough that like
if you just were like chaz bono i need
to know what she's doing oh
he sorry or uh
you know you go down a rabbit hole with
somebody from college i don't know
i know what you mean you know what's
funny there's a guy that i went to
college with
who uh
is a doctor in houston and i did a
show in houston i dropped out after a
year anyhow long story short
he's in a peruvian
ayahuasca retreat video wow really this
is one of these things like we were
never that close
did you reach out to him no because i
don't know how to get in touch
but it was like is that that guy yeah
because i didn't see him for
20 years and then saw him again
and then didn't saw him once in 2012 or
something and then
and i was like are you the guy who was
vegan and he's like yeah
he was like vegan he was cool yeah yeah
and he kept a food journal
that's weird that was because i i had a
[ __ ]
really funny joke which is uh his food
journal was like me
eat two eggs me get big it's in college
[ __ ] goodness is 18. um so i was like
you're the me
two eggs guys he's like yes um and
and then he's in an eye once it's a guy
that like you
should be friends basically are
following his yeah we should be friends
and just
it's just not happening well uh there's
a girl that i knew
i haven't talked to in a gazillion years
and um i'm so sad her
son who was four had cancer
and she would just post updates usually
i avoid that [ __ ] like the plague
but uh this one got yeah because they're
going to get you for money
and i just was following along on his
journey and it was so
sad having no idea how it might end
i mean they were like it was looking
good yeah
and um and then when she announced that
he died he was four
he was five when he died it was
so sad yeah it was obviously that's very
sad
uh it was just i found it weird that i
was crying like
i knew them and they were my family and
i knew him and i cried forever and even
if i like
explained the story i'll cry like uh and
you know what i did which was really
weird
he went on you know those helpful honda
guys
like sure i like wrote like
this woman her son died of cancer
because she still
after you passed she had so many
so much of his medical bills to pay
still yeah for years i think
and i just felt badly it's great it's
something to remember them by
you know what i mean like when they send
like victims to like clean up
bill yeah so
i just was i just felt so bad she had to
keep paying his medical bills after you
died
did the honda guys help he never
responded
not very helpful but
uh but yeah that's just it's just so sad
uh yeah yes um
another [ __ ] tell what tell your
partner something you like about them
already
like why why why do you want us to keep
doing that come on
come on guys
i i'll say that i like how
you don't
i don't know if it's intentional but
that you do not
fit a mold of any kind in terms of
how you live your life meaning you don't
you're not really pressed to like i need
to
find a husband no or i need to i
you don't really need to do anything
yeah which is which is
uh rare
i think for a fertile woman
i just feel like it'll happen if it's
going to happen
and me stressing about it is not going
to help it's funny because i went i
forgot which one we
did and didn't do yeah so i went all the
way back i just did
most of set two and three questions and
the one
it says what
role what roles do love and
affection play in your life and i
thought about i'm like love is never my
focus
yeah it's never ever been my focus to
like get a guy get a boyfriend get a
partner grow build maybe that's not
good but i don't but if it's not your mo
that's
you can't make it your ammo you can't i
can't like
brain we gotta like that you can't
make yourself be
that's the thing that i wanna say to
people
that are judgmental about
any choice someone makes right i mean
unless it's drug
unless it's like overly like destructive
um but even that is you
can't really force yourself to do
something you don't want to you
can't you can't do it for long i don't
it's not that i don't want to do it i
just think
i think if i focus on it it's a
not going to happen and be not going to
be what i want but
the doing in a premeditated way is
that's where it's like
that's what i love this year what this
year what are you even talking about
like how do you how do you decide in
this calendar year you sound like a
crazy person yeah
do you sound like a reality show person
a game
reality game show husband show a lot of
people are
though very much well that's that's your
ass you're going to get divorced
yeah i have friends that i'm just like i
can't i
can't focus on it because
it's if you focus on it's depressed
there's only one time in my life i've
ever been
like i need a boyfriend and it's because
the guy just prom
yeah right i went with the girl the
problem um so we so i didn't have to be
committed to one guy
hello look we all got it okay uh well i
just
my mom thought it was like i actually
didn't get it at all
um so uh
wait you well you were oppressed to find
a guy
oh because i dated a guy who
and i'm the coolest person today
i am never you gotta bring me here come
to my friends think
no man that's you that's me we don't
need to blend them unless
we really gotta [ __ ] blend you know
what i mean i'm very
averse to just being in a
super serious relationship and i
dated somebody who had enough
trauma going on that i mean i was doing
nothing we saw each other once a week
and he wanted to do this it wasn't like
i was pressing him
and he would always say things like
i just i feel like this is going so fast
i'm like we hang out once a week no it's
not
we don't even call you my boyfriend guys
juices have
no tie to reality it's so goddamn funny
to me
and so then my the problem is it would
be like pursue pursue pursue pursue
push away for a week a month
like drinking my bathwater push away and
it was the first time i had experienced
that so after
i'm like i just go
like you go go won't answer the call
100 phone calls i'm sorry and this is
that
okay i fall back into it this is going
too fast
it's too much i'm like yo dude what do
you want so when we broke up
mind you breakup was i just stopped
answering his phone call and he stopped
calling after two weeks he still thinks
you're dating go ahead
and he still thinks you're dating and
it's going too fast
but after that i think the reverse
psychology of telling me when i was
doing nothing wrong
you're you want too much for me
i we hung out two days a week and then i
took it down to one mm-hmm
and i still was weird so um
after that i think i got in my head
maybe i do want a boyfriend maybe i
that's what i i just got in my head for
a period and i
guess what i tried so hard to get a
boyfriend didn't happen and the guys
i was trying to make it work with we
weren't that compatible
it was terrible you can't reverse
engineer it
lesson learned i remember one guy who's
like i'm not looking for anything
serious but you're good at this
i was like [ __ ] i can't get a boyfriend
so i i went i snapped out of it i went
back to normal
binky but i i really did [ __ ] with me
for a second
it's just regular banking it's a regular
same old b um
wait i think i didn't tell you something
i didn't tell you um i think you
are tell your partner something that you
love about them already
uh you're so much more goofy
yeah it's you're so
you're a very funny goofy person
and you do not ever goofy on stage
you have like the basis is sometimes the
point of view can be
silly but yeah you're not goofy
on stage at all because it does i don't
get it because it's so
i know but it's you're better at being
goofy than a lot of people
of course but i find it of course
but i i don't mean like of course i mean
like yes but there's a certain thing in
comedy where
they won't respect you no no it's not
in common it's the audience it's like i
don't want that
from you who you don't want that in my
audience
the audience does not want that from me
in particular when i do it
i'll get like 20 of the crowd to laugh
really
which is like i can't you can't that's
not that's no margin
no that's not good those are terrible
and then there's certain people that
like
chris de stefano this new york comic
he the way he has a podcast called
history hyenas that
they release a lot of clips on him and
this guy giannis pappas and
[ __ ] really funny but
chris is so [ __ ] funny on the podcast
in a way that's almost impossible to be
on stage
yeah like it's all this like i'll tell
you what i like he's like over
cranked and like it's anxiety too stays
hun
and you almost can't do it and like
because i said i was like dude you got
to figure out a way to take
that that dalia actually figured out a
way to get his
sillier inside podcast jokes to his
onstage person good he's he
is good at being said but you know what
i would argue dalia has a
different challenge he can get away with
a lot
because he's he's like commanding of the
room
and so you on immediately want to be
down down with what is yeah for example
when
i'll see ian take the stage and i mean
like when i first started
and delete didn't have like yeah this
create i mean obvi
always very popular but as crazy of a of
a fan base and
just can take the stage and command
attention whereas let's say ian
yeah has to earn yes he has to earn
the fact that it's like oh no i'm
actually funny as [ __ ] and by the end of
it you'll know yes
but he has such low energy yeah that so
i feel like you're somewhere
in the middle in the middle of life and
i i know that there
it's just trying to figure out what
people i don't even know how people view
that's the other problem
i don't even know what how people view
me
in terms of if they if someone comes to
see me
i want to go like what do you think is
going to happen
are you yelling at them no no not what
do you think is gonna happen like
which what have you seen
of me that you like because it's like
neil come on no no i don't mean it like
hell i mean like do you or did you see
me on the daily show
which is like a very prescribed
political metaphor thing
did you see me on the breakfast club did
you see my twain speech do you see three
mics
you're more consistent than you're
giving yourself i'm not oh like they're
all kind of the same kind of
not the same but similar enough that if
you like one you'll like the other
yeah i'm with you i yes i guess it's
like i think that people
what people like about me is like
[ __ ]
unique thoughts and good metaphors like
if you had to
if i had to pick
so i don't know where silly plays and i
can be silly in the margins
yeah but i can't be silly in the middle
of a thing about
black lives matter you know what i mean
like i the problem is i talk about
relatively heavy things so it's like but
i think you're
wasting the your silliest the most on
this podcast
of course but a lot of people who
like you listen to this for that you
know it's like they know you
yes you feel like you can get away with
it more i guess if it's your show
then a blank canvas a showcase show
showcase what do you mean like that's
where the store is oh sure yeah
yeah exactly 912 people they came for
two of them
yeah so i don't i do fun crowd work in
person
yeah like but that get
can be silly but i know what you mean
it's just it's hard to know how to
integrate it
yeah it is it is it's also because
i feel like your silliness works in our
conversations a lot
yeah then just you know you're on your
own
like there's no time or even
no it's that's the thing about stand up
is it is so prescribed
in terms of like you have this much
space
and this you know
you have that people only accept a
certain
right type of thing or else that
it's just diminishing returns there's a
hbo
max or no it's on netflix i want to say
it's called
jake or something where it's a girl
playing a guy
doing a stand-up special that polar
directed i think
is it real or scripted or real
it's a i mean or a documentary
uh thing is it documentary
um no
no it's a stand-up show um
yeah natalie it's called nate
is what it's called but and that's one
of those things where like
it works but it's not getting big laughs
it's like silly and abstract and like
some of the abstract artsy but it's like
i can't
no no it's like it's got a black
barbershop rules
has to work in a black barbershop or at
least try to work in a black barbershop
um so
what if anything is too serious to be
joked about that's easy black barber
shops
next question uh nothing
really i there's nothing okay okay okay
i
that is two i know you're answering i
mean
you people were mad about a meg and
italian joke and then
what's funny is you liked it when you
heard chris made a magnifying joke
no i didn't know i didn't like the joke
that's i didn't like the joke
necessarily i like that we both made a
mega italian joke
no do you want to try it for another um
guess three
um no i just i laughed
at the absurdity that he asked
that he said that to her i don't we
shouldn't say what it is no
but he was almost like a point
he really asked her that [ __ ] but one to
her face
yeah she didn't like it yeah
you know there we go right but
none of it was the content it wasn't
like that was so funny it was just
some things i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious but oh no
it's like a yeah eric andre on the
street it's just it's like
the absurdity of the person's reaction
are like i can't believe you said that
that's kind of funny that wasn't
like yeah yeah um
as a comedian well you nothing is funny
you can't i mean nothing's definitely
enough yeah you can't
worry about because i i
if i think about it long enough i can
figure out a funny angle
okay but what i as a non-comedian was
thinking about
was okay i haven't heard many
maybe you do but like 9 11 jokes i mean
it's not that funny um
have you heard any good ones yeah
okay uh mass killings mass shootings
mass shootings they're not again it's
not that
funny possible no but it's like ugh
yeah what's the it just feels like
i'm gonna be edgy nothing's off limits
yeah i don't if you if you're there like
a black church getting
shot up is like of course i don't know
but
i'm saying i wrote mass killings mass
killing a black church
absolutely but i did i tell you the joke
that my buddy made
i didn't even know him and he told me a
joke he made a black guy made
after the space shuttle blew up which is
he's like you know what this means
white people singing gospel which is
[ __ ] hilarious
right like it's not
uh is it it's if you're if it's abstract
enough i just don't
i don't i believe that if there's a
chris had some good school shooting
jokes dave has a good
that good evacuation joke about like
well if you're teaching the kids how to
evacuate
you know the shooter's here like
that's a [ __ ] good job like it's not
impossible because we have to say
who's this subject is the subject that
people who are
dying it's kind of wow
of course yes there but then it's like
is that a joke about
that thing it's when people go don't
make don't joke about one it's like yeah
but
if you have a good enough comedy brain
you can figure out
who to make it so yeah yeah like i would
trust stan hope to do it i would trust
jessalyn anchored but we could just say
if you're not
maybe maybe if you're not
one of like a trusted headline comedian
i wouldn't i i just think there's
different levels there's different tiers
to what you can joke about
and um just that's like
big leagues yeah but those guys did it
before they were famous
did what make jokes that you're not
supposed to make
i feel like most people who aren't
famous make the jokes you're not
supposed to make
it doesn't mean are they good eat jokes
you're not supposed to make no that's
what i'm saying
that do it or burr or whatever like
there are guys that can do it
but most we're talking about the greats
when they weren't known
so yeah trees did a joke about
a 911 joke which is uh
like in november of that year
somebody got pushed in front of a train
and patrice was like
new york is back it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's yeah but that's
abstract but he's not famous it's
it's again it's like is that a 911 joke
yeah yes but
does someone die yep it's i think
i'm trying to make like uh there's just
no
hard fast rules about it yeah because
you can
you know steve harvey on seinfeld said a
great thing about
as comics we have the joke the day it
happens
right just when are you guys ready to
hear it that's true it's like we don't
and that's him who doesn't even like
play that game
right like but we have the joke
my brain already came up with a joke
it's just when are you
[ __ ] ready to hear this joke like but
it's our
unless it's directly affecting and even
if it's directly affecting you it's like
your brain will still shoot out a joke
right a beautiful
a big beautiful joke um
if you were to die this evening with no
opportunity to communicate with anyone
what would you most regret not having
told someone
why haven't you told them yet
go i'm pretty direct
i'll say that um
but has there been anything you haven't
you've avoided
like not avoided but you haven't you
haven't been in a position to say to
somebody that you would like to
no well i mean i've got um too many
vengeance wants to count
i've got too much vengeance we don't
have you'd need a second vengeance over
here
yeah uh that so i you can't i don't even
include that
this seems more like
not having in some here's
here's the here's
thinking about this question earlier i
was like i would want to tell
people that they were wrong about me but
it's like
everyone you know what i mean but at
which point you go
are you sure they were wrong right so i
have all this [ __ ] where
i could i could go like you shoulda
i don't know man i don't
maybe not yeah but there's nobody that
that i don't it's it's also worthwhile
is it worth telling so and so that he
hurt my feelings
um you know yeah
for what and then it's like just so you
know look i have some
i have some news first news is neil died
second news is
you really disappointed him like
you know what there's nothing
positive that i haven't
said to people yeah
i thought about this question and i was
like well there's
one or there's a few family members that
have bones to pick but i feel like if
i'm dying yeah if you're it i think it
should be
positive positive communication only
i agree and i what i wrote was negative
i'm like no
i didn't like write it but every bone i
had to pick was
a negative thing of someone who's done
something towards me
it was wrong to me yeah and then
when i think about it if you're dying
just [ __ ] focus on the bad focus
focus on the acts get the accent keep
grinding to the left i want my last
motion on earth to be grinding my axe
yeah so just positive positive things
yeah and do you feel like there are a
lot of positive things you haven't said
to people no
yeah i don't see that i like saying
positive things yeah me too i think it's
i think you like have to yeah you can be
generous with that
especially in a thing that's i always
try to be positive to people in showbiz
like if i like something i like get the
person's number
great job it's blank blank
and i literally make them guess who
blank is and what blank has to say
number 34. so me and bianca are two
two cool guys too great to
to be negative but you want to go
negative but it's not like tell my mama
she knows they'll know your house
containing everything you own catches
fire
after saving your loved ones and pets
you have time to safely make a final
dash to save any one item what would it
be
and why um this was hard but
i think there's one photo the only photo
of my
mom my dad together not that that
matters it's just a really cool photo
it's very
80s have you taken a have you gotten it
digitized
no it's one of those 80s like um olin
mills
sure and it's like uh canvassy and yeah
it's like my dad's profile yeah my mom's
in here it's a classic
it's so amazing and the wood it's just a
really nice frame
solid wood so i would i would say well
what i would say is tonight
take a picture of it with your phone
right no i have one okay
but i would like to get it digitally i
just i don't want to
undo it yeah i mean because it isn't a
it's in like a solid the original yeah
it's in a solid
i this might be crazy you might be able
to improve on that olin mills frame
again it's tight pie in the sky okay
it's pretty exciting all right it adds
to everything it's part of the like
dissolve in the head yeah and a
modern frame would look weird okay
um you know they up in palo alto they
have a garbage day you could probably
find it
santa clara santa clara [ __ ] um
i don't this thing is
my computer i mean i don't my computer
my passport you don't go to cloud
no but that's the key
um what about your
photo of obama
i got i got digis okay
how about your
my bow flex good it's kind of say both
yes
i wheel it out because i can do it
because i'm strong enough
because i've been working with a bowflex
isn't there i feel like you have some
nice commemorative things
isn't there one you cherish i've got to
say i'm not that big on commemorative
items
a million in your house yes but i don't
that's uh that's a fake out i do that
to get you off my set a lot going on i
don't like i don't
would my 2004 bet award
i i don't care like i i don't none of it
means or my writers
or shrimp my shrimp is funny like the
shrimp i would get i'd get this set
you better will where i get our set
and uh but there's not that much
even when people lock their door i'm
kind of like how much are tv's worth
150 come on what are tv's worth no a
used cv
you don't want someone in your 60 inches
150
i saw an ad from best buy that said
come pick it up it's yours you don't got
to pay they got so many tvs
but their new slogan that's so much
check it out uh they
yeah so i guess uh my passport i can't
really think of anything that i would
want
like i don't i don't have
i don't have any items that are
irreplaceable and the re
i don't like when i my if i have like a
trophy or something i have a prop prop
from the goods
2009 car movie carpet you're gonna give
it to me i have like a prop arm that
everybody signed
i just it doesn't it either feels braggy
or unnecessary
so you'd be fine with this whole three
four steps
on fire right now to keep i'll i won't
break eye contact
i just don't i no there's nothing that i
would absolutely your soda stream
well but i can get a new one there's
nothing that i can't get a new one of
and the trophies
i never think about okay okay so now
it's because i want you to play the game
you can't replace anything you can only
replace like a very small amount of
stuff okay
him
uh let's say like computer phone no yeah
i figured that
sodastream i'm going sodastream
so bad bubbly water makes you burp and
he loves the verbs
oh it's so great those side burps um
of all the people in your family whose
death would you find most disturbances
it's like this ques it's dark disturbing
uh isn't all death disturbing
uh who's what i find most well
all right i'll play the game come on
please which is how
your dad died so my dad died too
yay so somehow um
he was already your dad died more um
who you ever wonder like how am i going
to react if such and such dies
yeah i try not to think about that but
yeah i think about it all the time
any free moment i have um that's a good
it's a worthwhile
uh like how
okay let's talk about let's say our moms
died
no i would cry
were i to cry it would be for
the
limitations of her life do you know what
i mean
and that's now over yeah for sure and
there's a line in that in the movie um
affliction which is the greatest
drunk drinking addiction um
codependence movie ever and uh
there's a line where a woman says
she she's talking about a woman who's
married to an alcoholic she goes
people like her go through life with the
sound off
which is like by the way speaking of the
sound off if you watched uh
sound of metal that knew yeah [ __ ] i
i started crying
there's a point where he's he's losing
his hearing and it was i know i saw him
terrifying it was scary yeah it gave me
anxiety
yeah it's really scary it was like um
uh i would cry that's why i think i
would cry
is for and again maybe she
to her it's not no for her she's like
i'm old i did a good look at my kids
yeah
look at my life yeah uh
so that's why i think i think my mom's
death
i i don't think it's close would upset
me the most
um and i would think that would be true
for everybody
in my family i guess for me we're in any
family really
for sure i'd be very upset obviously my
mom but i guess my little sister because
i don't know yeah i don't have any
little i don't have any younger
yeah younger it's like you're not
supposed to die
yeah before me yeah i get yeah my niece
and nephews
um there's something just uh
if it happens i'm absurdly unfair yeah
that's when a young person died it's
like
boy this is [ __ ] uh as a guy who's
been
falsely convicted of murder twice in
past lives this is not fair
dude kevin neeland has a [ __ ]
hillary's jokes
has a hilarious joke i i'm gonna butcher
but it's something like
you know at the morgue you hate to see
some
like an adult with braces i don't it's
very
it's kevin neal is [ __ ] so funny so
it's all you could predict what he was
gonna what the joke was gonna be about
you can never or that one he does that
whole thing where the audience basically
fills in the blank for yeah half the
joke yeah
he's like hey he's telling the jokes
yeah yeah he just has a likable
he's just a lot of charisma
you know that like that's like sneaky
really sneaky because he's not
he's like the lead on a matt leblanc
show
it's sneaky it's almost like one of the
sorry the only guys who's hosted weekend
update that you forget
posted it and his and was good at it
it's because
he's almost like the the
someone pulling a coin out of your ear
yeah and you're like oh that's so
funny that's his humor is very yes
fun like you know what else his problem
is he's not
28. it really helps in comedy to be
28. okay but everyone re
like got reintroduced to him on
weeds then he had no no of course no
i'm not saying those numbers he's got
he's got no i'm saying i think if you
he doesn't have one if he got a project
that was a prime time project i think
he'd be re
everybody would re fall in love with him
you know
yeah but that's where the age thing
comes in because it's like
matt leblanc's 50 something too but um
but he was joey so yeah
yeah really
[Music]
neelan has some of the best single jokes
he is the best
caitlyn jenner joke i've ever heard
which is uh
caitlyn uh
he's like i saw caitlyn and and i knew
bruce
before he died which is [ __ ]
hilarious and true because he used to
play golf with russian
right and it's like yeah before he died
that's what happened to him
he died bruce did die
caitlyn gets to live in his house and
have keep all his money
um share a personal problem
and ask your partner's advice an hour
she might handle it also ask your
partner to reflect back to you
how you seem to be feeling about the
problem you have chosen
uh oh bianca honey can you
start doing this why um
uh problem
well the the the problem
the book writing is still a problem what
book writing
i talked about writing a book last year
yeah so what's the problem well
i can't write a snitch book yeah
but as i said earlier i have a unique
experience on earth okay but i don't
know
how to write about it without
without naming without
talking a lot about not dave would be
the only person i'd talk a lot about
and it's a it would just be it's all
it's a lot of it's private so i just
think it's i just can't do it
how am i supposed to help you that tell
me what to do
what would you do write a children's
book and make an alias for everybody
but just tell everyone that like look
the
most famous people in the world they're
characters in the book then everyone
will buy that book and try
i know but again i don't want to play
that game of like ooh
i have access to these p like
what do you want what's the difference i
want i can't i know i can't
i can't write it it's a shame it's a
sham
um that was a tricky
well that's the like the only problem i
have
that is like um
haven't you got another problem
uh oh mine was gonna be okay mine is a
so i'm gonna ask a dating advice because
everyone else asks
us dating advice and i never ask you so
i always end up in the same situations
right
meet a guy he's a little overly
anxious at the beginning um
i counter that with massive amounts of
support
and emotional generosity
what are they a bit like of an anxious
attacher
okay they're like desperate
but like like it's just a very
metabolism often yeah like they gotta
eat
a lot but not so obnoxious but i don't
know if they're hiding it
but it eventually it's like a lot of
emotions a lot of emotions
um and then i
if i like them enough i will counter it
with support
emotional generosity reassurance it's
all good
you might scare me away though so chill
and then it becomes kind of a
it becomes you know
a stereotype in our relationship where i
am
the giving one i'm emotionally i can be
very emotionally supportive
and they end up always taking it for
granted
and um somehow i become the ugly fat
chick
not like they don't treat me right but
the way they take
my niceness for granted he's so weird
because it's like you're kind of [ __ ]
up right
i'm being really great for you
yeah and i'm actually going without a
lot of nice things in relationships
which is
having a little bit like a little bit of
return on my
investment yeah exactly um
and then i bounce
somehow it just or it ends or they break
up whatever
um always in like an emotional tailspin
that they're going through
and then i'm not gonna say they always
regret it i don't know but it always is
like
trying to get back and it just is like
this cycle
and i'm like you know first couple times
it was him
now i'm like i think it might be me i
don't know why i
like am i over
extending myself emotionally at the
beginning too much
like you're to me you're establishing
the rules
of engagement and once you've
established the rules
those are the rules i find people
the amount of intimacy
because of sex that two strangers
like find themselves in like you
wouldn't be like this with a
woman or a guy if someone paid you to be
like this
like you the same person you're not
sexually attracted to or getting sexual
gratification from you wouldn't
deal with [ __ ] anything with any of
this [ __ ] yeah so
i don't think that's how people should
behave but i think people should maybe
think about behaving like that a little
bit
in that case like how would i treat a
uh new female friend who was acting like
this you'd be like
uh you got issues uh yeah yeah
um look uh
yeah so i think you've got a
you've got just treat it throw some of
that in the
in the barbie let's throw another
boundary on the bottom like just throw
up throw
throw throw about just a little bit of
realism of like yeah
you know what like no i'm doing that no
um yeah and and
and the thing that you as much as we
joke about red flags being
attractive i think they are
i know i was thinking about that because
like [ __ ]
they actually aren't they all give me
very a lot of anxiety
but i've been single for so long like i
only
started doing more serious relationships
not that long ago but compared to
everybody else so long ago but not that
long ago compared to everybody else like
people have
long-term relationships in their like
early 20s you know i avoided that
um so i
think for a while i just was like is
this
what people do i guess this is
how to be a good girlfriend is to
be cool when someone's freaking out and
be nice and kind and try to
help them through it now i realize
there's a lot of energy suckers out
there
there's a lot of people who will cling
on to you for dear life
but also suck your energy and also call
you manipulate like all this [ __ ]
right
so now i'm a little
when a red flag comes like i get a
little hot under the collar just like
they're never not what you think they
are that's not gonna
go away one of the problems is you have
to nip
[ __ ] in the bud you have to date someone
for a week
and then basically say i don't want to
date you
because you're [ __ ] weird you have to
figure out a different way to say but
that's what
and in some ways it's almost
dispiriting if as a person where you're
like i'm just [ __ ] writing people off
left and right
yeah but meanwhile you got to write them
off
there's no other the the op it's too bad
options
yeah either they are uncomfortable and
upset or you are
[ __ ] in a silent hostage situation
yeah uh
it's it's just a waste of time
yeah it's unfortunately it's like oh no
that's a waste of time
yeah it would be i'd get my [ __ ] ate
from the back
everything all the things but all your
stuff
you know your stuff uh but you just
would it's just not
worth the trump it's it
there's a thing in la where when
projects are going
when like you got a movie that got
greenlit that's people treat you like
you've got some magic you're you've got
some
you're a warlock right but that people
will
agree to projects because they just want
to be on a boat that leaves the harbor
mm-hmm and they want them you want them
i'm a viable
person and i'm on a boat so as dating
people you want to go
i'm on a boat to sleep in the harbor but
they all
most of them sink so it's like just
don't get on a boat
you seem weird but pick
or yeah either get on boats and bring a
[ __ ] life jacket
because they're all going to sink or
just don't don't get on boats
or just be selective about what boats
you get on
yeah that's the weird thing it's like
there's even times when i've been
extremely selective
and it's like oh it's sinking no yeah
even the ones that you don't think
you're gonna sink how are you
[ __ ] mental how did i not see how
mental you were
yeah i know a girl who dated who's dated
like the worst guys in l.a
like literally i used to say like you
only date villains huh
and she like she's like i tried to make
a turn over new leaf and
and i was seeing the guy and then i
found out or i realized that he
was like a pathological liar
and i just cut bait and left and the
fact that i could even do that was a big
deal
but there are
that we don't have it's hard to know
what people are like and if you
once you realize you can't bargain with
them
that's what they're like there's not it
ain't it's immutable it's not gonna
change
um if it does it's through no effort of
yours
it's an accident um so
just you just gotta be like nope sorry
good no i know and that's the thing i
used to i talked about on here before
it's like
being able to discern what someone's
probably like
and your suspicion and you're like
look and then once you've already
slept with them that's where it's damn
near impossible
yeah it's damn near impossible to get
out of that
without feeling like an [ __ ] an
[ __ ]
and they're very hurt yeah
very deeply extremely hurt that's why
in this weird twisted way some like in a
weird not like a machiavellian way but
i don't mind being broken up with i
haven't mind it being broken up with
it even when i act like it takes the
it takes the it's way easier there's no
guilt
no there's just none you're just like oh
what's that i'm bad
i'm not no good okay yeah
that was great you can just move on a
lot easier
probably it's like i mean it's like
you're you don't
uh there's no upkeep you don't have to
worry about them
can we just meet they never want to just
meet if they break up with you they
don't ever want to see you again as a
matter of fact
no that's not true but yeah well guys
want to keep the lines
and so they can sleep with you i mean
there has been
over overreaches outside of
trying to [ __ ] i'm just like dude
what what's happening
anyways but you know people are weird
yeah you just have to
you have to assume that it's not going
to work no
no no yes you agree with me you have to
just agree
with you well that's why it's the thing
of like will i
find love i hope so
but it's just getting to the point where
i'm like ah
statistically this seems seems pretty
hard i'm getting weirder
right i'm only getting weirder she's
getting more work she
works i've got schedules i've got
magnets
um i'm getting weirder and women
are getting more independence this can't
be good
i mean honestly i think the more
independent women i i
women's expectations are getting higher
and my ex
and i'm getting more peculiar so it's
like what are the [ __ ] odds this is
gonna work
where i'm not even like i want something
crazy but just
it's a miracle anytime i've been in love
with somebody that's my takeaway it's
like
this is a [ __ ] mirror i don't know
how this happened
but it's a it's a blessed miracle
um so but i wish that for
you guys on because it's valentine's day
no it's not
it's december um again okay
we're in love we're in love we leave us
alone
privacy at this time he's
um goodbye goodbye
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
bye